right good evening everybody
welcome to the Development Committee
13th of December 2018 or usual
evacuation announcement first should we
be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit of the
chamber or assembly point is in public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your evacuation by
collecting any belongings please don't
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please also note that the meeting will
be audio recorded and if you have a
mobile please turn it to silent thank
you
just before we properly get started
there is an addendum can I just check
that everybody has got the addendum and
seen the contents oh dear i can'ts the
griffin the addendum does cover three of
the items can you make sure you're
familiar with the contents before you
determine to vote looking at it as you
go okay right okay apologies for absence
then have been received in the office
for councillor mr. short and councilor
mrs. Shaw we've got our substitute
members councillor Gooding for mrs. Shaw
councillor FD for mr. Shaw on
non-members attending councilor mr. Hoyt
councillor Stanley councilor mountain
and councillor Ward and we have the
meeting minutes of the meeting held on
the 22nd of November 2018 happy for me
to sign those as a correct and accurate
record of that meeting thank you item 5
declarations of interest accounts the
Steptoe thank you german with regards to
item 6 at the airport two things i'm on
the airport consultative committee
and also the council counsel for the
area and with regards to item 8.1 King
emerald school again that comes in my
division that's county councillor Thank
You councillor Williams Thank You
chairman
likewise item six the airport I'm on the
airport liaison committee and item 8.1 I
have relatives working at kids and also
I am the I'm the chairman of Roger
Parish Council Thank You councillor
missus hi-yah interest over fairways but
I have eaten in there cat no I don't see
that as a major conflict anyone else
okay
so just for our visitors this evening if
I just explain how things work we have
our officers present a report first of
all then if there is a pre organized
speaker they're able to speak we've got
two over there then non members of the
committee are able to make their
statement but they only get the one
opportunity to make that statement then
it's open to members of the committee to
discuss to seek any clarifications from
officers and ultimately to take a vote
on whether an item is to be passed or
not
so our first item this evening is our
item six new airport terminal building
at Southend Airport
right okay I assure you I came in here
at five to seven and I said is it all
working I was given the thumbs up and we
said but on the 735 minutes to go that
time has elapsed and now we've got
honestly seven just before seven it was
spot-on yeah
just go
come to life on our or go bit further
remember so I will just adjourn the
meeting for five minutes and we thump a
few bits of electric
we're not having much luck with the
device that sends a signal to the camera
at the moment if that device is not
going to work we're not going to we're
not going to move forward down here so
while we're just doing a few more bits
and pieces here we're investigating
whether we can get the required
information up in room 4 if that is the
case then we'll need a few minutes to
reset up there but if this does it come
to life and room for isn't capable of
retrieving the signal then we will have
no alternative but to cancel the meeting
so please bear with us in the interim
[Music]
I've got I've got I need to wait for
officers before we continue but I just
come down to adjourn the meeting however
don't just don't go near it
[Music]
all right we got everyone right
you can only apologize for the delay as
long as no one touches that particular
bit of equipment we believe we're ready
to go so we're at item six new airport
terminal building at London South End
Airport Rochford Thank You chairman this
proposed list for extensions to the
terminal building and associated
development at Southend Airport two
extensions are proposed one to the North
elevation and one to the south the
extension to the North elevation would
also feature an enclosed compound to
house plant at ground level
in addition here between the proposed
extension and the control tower an
additional area of hard standing is
proposed take you to the elevations so
the top elevation there
so the top elevation on this plan shows
the proposed northern elevation would be
two-story so that's from about this
point here extending northwards and the
extension would be at the same height as
the existing terminal building the
extension to the south is very similar
to an extension that was approved
earlier this year and a single-story
this extension would have a part flat
part curved roof the extension to the
northern elevation would have a curved
roof don't worry about zooming well if
you can the extension to the northern
elevation would have a curved roof
mimicking the roof of the existing
terminal building but then would rise up
in a sort of wave form to the airside
elevation of the building when viewed
from the air side the two-story
extension would appear different from
the existing building with full height
glazing up to two-story level if I can
take you to the next plan showing the 3d
images can perhaps see that quite more
clearly here so the roof form curves and
then gently curves upwards
unlike the existing building and then
you've got this two-story height glass
and behind a brief Salette is proposed
just to shield the sunlight into the
first floor the first floor intended for
use and for various sort of commercial
uses and uses in association with the
airport office is considered that the
design and form of the two-story
extension is in keeping with the
existing building and will represent
good design with materials matching
corresponding parts of the existing
building the compound to house the plant
which is shown so that's to the north of
the proposed northern extension which is
this part here would be a steel mesh and
would complement the modern design of
the airport building the extension
proposed to the southern elevation is
more functional in design and would
retain the existing
a single story element here with a
curved roof would involve flat-roofed
extensions either side this element of
the building is perhaps less invisible
to the public realm the proposed
extensions if I can take you to the site
plan so if this line here is the
existing terminal building this is a
two-story element and then this is the
existing single-story parts flat-roofed
side extensions here and then this is
the two-story now extension to the North
elevation and with the compound and just
surrounding the proposed extensions are
significant to the terminal building but
only the first-floor part of the
proposed two-story extension is actually
additional floor space compared to the
extensions that have already been
granted planning permission here the
joint area action plan supports the
growth of the airport and recognizes
that the terminal building would would
need to be extended the additional floor
space at ground floor is largely to
support functional requirements relating
to baggage handling the first floor
space is not proposed for specific
end-users at present but would be put to
uses that support and enhance the
customer experience at the airport there
is one slight change to the wording of
condition nine as reported on the
addendum as that condition wording had
included some text that was meant for
explanation and clarification so the
first sentence would remain but then the
clarification after that would be
incorporated partly into the reason for
that condition subject to the proposed
conditions officers recommend approval
of the scheme which accords with
relevant planning policy and the adopted
development plan so as just mentioned
there are two additional conditions 14
15 and an adjustment to condition 9 and
remembers wish to speak on this one okay
good so the recommendation is for
approval those members in favor of
approval please indicate
thank you that is unanimously approved
item seven fairways garden center home
Bridge Road Raley Thank You chairman
this proposal is for outline planning
permission for the redevelopment of a
mixed-use site for 16 dwellings the only
matter reserved for consideration at a
later date is landscaping all other
matters are for consideration in the
determination of this application the
site has a frontage onto Hall Bridge
Road and is opposite the Raley Club
several residential properties here here
lie in proximity of the site take you to
the aerial image this gives an
indication of the current use of the
site there are a number if it won't work
it doesn't matter because actually this
this site plan also gives an indication
of the current use of the site you can
see that there are a number of buildings
and a varying design and scale generally
concentrated centrally but also towards
the northern and southern boundaries and
fighters almost entirely hard-surfaced
with various story juices and parking
provision dotted throughout the existing
access is positioned centrally onto
Holdrege Road this application of a can
take you to the proposed site plan
please is a resubmission following
members decision to refuse planning
permission for an earlier scheme this
year the previous scheme is currently at
appeal with a decision pending from an
inspector the earliest scheme was
refused for four reasons one of the
reasons for refused with the earliest
scheme related to the loss of business
at the site and the loss of employment
opportunities whilst policy Edie one
does seek to support protection
enhancement of the role of small and
medium businesses members will note the
table provided in the committee report
which details the level of employment
provided by current businesses at this
site the level of employment provided is
low some businesses have relocated
within the district or plan to an
employment relating to these would
therefore not be lost
the secondary's of perfuse are related
to the location of the site and issues
of sustainable development the site does
not to join an existing defined
settlement however it does lie almost
equidistant between two large
settlements with sufficient surrounding
Greenbelt to ensure that the site's
redevelopment would not result in the
merging of these two the applicant has
proposed in this application if I can
take you to the next plan please so the
applicant is proposing this application
to include a crossing on Hall Bridge
Road a pedestrian crossing to enable
residents of the site to safely cross
over to access existing bus stops
members will note this requirement is
ahead of term for the legal agreement a
slight amendment is recommended to
require a detailed plan to be submitted
to and agreed by the local planning
authority in consultation with Essex
County Council highways for this
crossing as indicative lis shown on
these on the drawings referred to in the
report the provision of this crossing
increases the sustainability of the site
occupants would have ready access to a
bus service a long-haul bridge road can
take you back to the site plan please
because her concern was also raised with
regard to the earlier scheme in terms of
the development being quite
inward-looking the only change that's
happened in this application is that
these dwellings here have been turned so
that they now face horbet Road and have
a more visible presence along this
prominent strip officers considered that
that's an improvement to the scheme it
improves the relationships of the
development to the prominent road
frontage and results in a less
inward-looking to scheme Essex County
Council highways have provided a
consultation response and raised no
objection subject as various conditions
unfortunately the response was not
received in time to be included in the
addendum the Highways Authority raised
no objection to the three proposed
accesses the existing one and then the
one to serve the two dwellings fronting
Hall Bridge Road
I'll briefly show you some of this is
just one of the elevations of one of the
dwelling types on the site these are the
same as were previously proposed the
scale foreman appearance of the
dwellings are considered acceptable as
is the layout finally consumers relays
raised in relation to the earlier
proposal with regard to the provision of
affordable housing members will recall
that the scheme's financial viability
was tested in respect of the earlier
application and that this was
independently examined by the valuation
office it was concluded that the scheme
could not viably provide 35% affordable
housing but could provide a contribution
of some six hundred and thirty three
thousand pounds the council's policy
seeks however the affordable housing be
provided on the site unless this is
proved impossible the applicant has now
agreed to the provision of to on-site
affordable dwellings and ahead of term
to a legal agreement to achieve this has
been recommended subject to the
recommended conditions and heads of
terms of the 106 legal agreement
including the slight amendment to the
106 head to require a detailed plan of
the crossing to be agreed and the
addition of the recommended highways
conditions as officers deem appropriate
the recommendation is one of approval
mr. Hawley Thank You chairman I think
I've got a couple of promise to this but
first of all I'd like to say I think
it's I mean they have improved what was
kind before us previously so that's
welcome there's questions we don't know
how we want to deal with not be able to
come back to them if possible but I
don't know then what you know I'm afraid
you know from where you sit I'm afraid
you're gonna get the wrong guy the the
first one is about the section 106 head
of state of term I so that's on page 7.1
under 1.1 1.1 a I'm on page seven point
one of the report we have the the
provision of two on site for all units
has already mentioned or the communal
commuted some of six hundred thirty
three thousand if no housing
provider can be found it's to me there's
this is a bit loose art does it reset
within two years ten years five years
quite often section 106 F sort of five
years ten years this one has nothing and
what on what basic mean how do we what
control have we got over that this is
all down to the developer deciding if
they can find one annoy it doesn't it
doesn't give much comfort shall say and
as I understand it we still don't have a
policy for the using of commuted sums is
that can we still are we able to receive
the community sums that's that question
so there's two questions within that
which perhaps could be answered for
other members if possible the second one
was within the report for visits visitor
spaces it does say that we could and I
accept this and it seems reasonable to
me is that within the landscaping for
reserved matters at the requirement to
provide for visitor spaces that I can't
see that in the report forgive me if
he's but I can't see that in the
landscaping condition so could that
would that be possible to be added by a
member of the visiting member they're
really that the two points okay how's
the mountain Thank You chairman the the
to outward facing properties I don't
know is it possible to have that image
back on the screen can you just advise
how they are going to access their
parking spaces do they access them from
the main road
dude where was no no down because that's
just a concern if they you know it's
more and more junctions on the main road
but so that was my observation thank you
thank you
councillor Ward Thank You chairman with
regard to parking I believe on 4.12
councillor Hoyas question is answered
because it's gonna require 32 spices
together with additional before visitor
parking spaces I believe that is
actually within the document on reading
councillor Stanley Thank You chairman
looking at the the site itself I'd like
to know before anything starts is what
the surface water maze with agreement is
a modeling for for that sort and also
the crossing across a very very busy
road I'm hoping that that will be either
a signal crossing rather than the
reservoir crossing which is there at
them or these could be put in as that is
not a purpose crossing so it needs to be
a fit for purpose not just an island in
the middle of that road because that's
that's not not sufficient with that many
children coming off of that road because
it's very dangerous very very dangerous
as you know that's my concerns and also
how the management of those ponds are
going to be and and where that water is
going to be distributed to thank you
okay right each of our visiting members
had their opportunity just before the
the members start to have their
discussions you want to cover some of
those points just to see give a bit more
clarity to the discussion
so I'm taking them in order so 1.1 a
it's just a head of the section 106 term
so it is brief and there will be a lot
of additional wording associated with
that including timings so the
requirements for the affordable units to
be provided you know at a certain point
within the development and there will be
requirements for a provider to be found
and justification if a provider cannot
be found so that the council is
satisfied there's an absolute last
resort if you like a fallback a payment
would be accepted in lieu of that and
the council can accept a payment and
that can be put towards affordable
housing within the district and that
again will be clarified in the 106 so it
is brief but and there's a lot of sort
of additional wording and clauses that
go around that to ensure as far as
possible that the two dwellings are
provided on that site in terms of
visitor spaces in the landscaping I
think the because it's an outline
application landscaping is a reserved
matter so one of the first conditions is
that the reserved matters application
would have to be consumed it'ld and
approved so essentially the outline is
part of the planning consent and it's
not a full consent and parking layouts
would all be part and parcel of that the
landscaping and the layout so we can
deal with the visitor parking within
that landscaping scheme which members
will we'll see when that reserve matter
application would come forward in terms
of accessing the parking spaces yes
those two properties would access their
parking spaces from Hall bridge road and
the Highways Authority are satisfied
with that officers are satisfied with
that otherwise what you get in any
scheme is development very much
inward-facing
and a weight and you don't get a good
sort of design
layout of the road frontage which is
important in the public realm
what highways have required by condition
and unfortunately if you've not seen the
highway response in full but they do
require sufficient space within these
two plots to enable these cars to exit
in forward gear so that and that that
will be one of the conditions the
surface water modeling yes so in the
report there is a section on surface
water drainage for point nine to four
point two two it talks about the
drainage proposal that has been
submitted and what they're proposing is
an attenuation Basin
so essentially what they will do is hold
surface water on that site and then it
will drain from the site to a sewer
connection at a controlled rate and the
highways of lead local field authority
are satisfied with that there are some
conditions that are quite detailed to
ensure that that happens and then the
crossing the crossing the reason why I
have suggested tonight that we require
some additional detail is that the plan
that's been provided as its County
Council haven't given us the absolute
okay to so what we're saying is we have
to have a plan that is submitted and
agreed and it works on the plan that's
been submitted as an indicative
indication in case highways for their
own safety requirements require some
slight tweaks to the position or the
details that have been submitted around
that crossing thank you very much
councillor Griffin
Thank You chairman the two bus stops can
they both be reached by a foot part from
the estate area is there a footpath on
either side of the road not all the way
along so on so the proposal is to have a
crossing here or somewhere along this
road frontage on Holdrege Road that
would enable the residents to safely
leave the site cross whole Beach Road
and then get to the bus stop that's on
the opposite side of the road to the
site there is also a bus stop on the
same side and there's outside of the
applicants ownership some grass verge at
the side of the road so it's not a
proper you know adopted pavement but
there is the ability for the people to
cross slightly further down and opposite
and that crossing and there is sort of
you know to a bumped surface but there's
not a platform in the middle of the road
at that point lower down so what we're
seeking to do on this application is
Achieva crossing to one of the bus stops
but it we couldn't enable them to sort
of require an adopted foot way all the
way along the other side okay thank you
castle westerns thank chairman just a
I'm getting confused with the figures on
page seven point one and one point one a
you've got a figure of six three three
four to nine then on page seven point
eighteen and 7.19 you have a figure of
six six three four to nine can you tell
me which is the correct figure please
so it's 4.10 on 7.19 and 4.6 on 7.18
clarify that one for you in amount in a
moment
counselor mrs. hoy yes again ignoring
our policy of 35 homes so I'd like to
ask when they seek to prove that they
can't afford it do we sing some do we do
that report or do they have to go and
find that report their sales the members
indicating to speak at this point I
think chairman it's not really to do
with the planning itself it's to do with
the fact that there's a pending appeal
on this site and it's really what would
happen with a decision on that against a
decision on this this what's the
relationship it's not it's not relevant
to our decision tonight but if they get
this and they win the appeal they can
choose to develop either so take them in
order well there is there is a
discrepancy between the figures quoted
however I would say that the report on a
number of occasions on pages seven one
eight and seven one nine talks at
references a figure of six six three
point four to nine so I would think that
maybe the figure on one point one a is
Type O and so the the actual correct
figure should be six six three four to
nine in any case potentially what we
could minute is that the the figure
should be the figure that was the
the difference from the viability report
that has been independently looked at so
whilst I think it's six six three four
to nine it needs to be well I would
recommend that one point one a is the
figure that we have in the reports and I
think we're just trying to source that
now but it needs to be the difference
basically it needs to be the figure that
was in the report that our consultant
has looked up and the minutes will
clarify that should we come to a
decision it's six six three and then yes
so on the issue of viability we look at
this closely so on any application where
the applicant is not saying at the
outset that they're going to provide 35
percent affordable housing in line with
our policy we require them to go and get
a report on that looks at all the
viability so there's a lot of financial
information build costs there's all
manner of information that comes
together and ends in a conclusion which
is is it viable or not to provide a 35%
and if it's not then what can the site
viably provide the applicants went away
and got their report done and we require
them to pay for it to be independently
tested and we the council chose who we
wanted to go out independently test we
generally go out to and the district
valuer and we did in this case and they
had a lot of questions of the report and
of the consultant done it on behalf the
applicant so there's a bit of chewing
and fro with the district value are
querying things and it going to and fro
and eventually what you get is a
district value of saying to the council
that this is what this site can viably
provide and so that's where we're at at
the moment with this we can have the two
dwellings on the site and we will seek
to ensure that they are provided on site
because that is what the policy requires
if that proves impossible essentially
because a provider is not on board
despite best efforts then the
contribution the council will get is six
six three four to nine
and and then I think councillor Smith
already mentioned the appeal which will
just play out its course so that may be
refused it may be approved and if
there's two approvals obviously it's in
the applicants gift as to which one they
implement and if they're both reviews it
go on to either eat by members we've had
a presentation we've had a lot of
questions answered and had a discussion
the recommendation on 7.1 is for
approval subject to the extra
information required with regard to the
crossing and the discussion with Essex
highways connect an ask them those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those it get
those against
just so
okay just keep your hand up for the time
being though one thank you that item is
approved thank you
item number eight which is a referred
item again that there's information on
the addendum with regard to this one
this is I can get Minh school and warm
clothes Rochford single-story flat roof
building uses a Children's Day Nursery
Thank You chairman okay this application
relates to King ed in the school which
is located at the end of a cul-de-sac in
full house in Watford King Edmonds
school is a mixed secondary school in
Preiser sixth form planning permission
is being sought to erect a single storey
building in the southwestern corner of
the school site the building would be
used as a nursery to accommodate 50
children between the age range of under
twos and up to five years of age like
most nurseries sessions will be held in
the morning and afternoon or all day um
as you can see from these photographs
that I'm showing you and this piece of
land is currently vacant from any
development and is used as a car park
for these six bull mares
so this is one end of the site you have
a photographs with the opposite end of
the site currently the access is gained
from Oxford Road cars also leads the
site by this access this axis is also
used for residents to gain access to
their garages
as part of the proposal it is proposed
to lay out landscape and around the
proposed building and lay out 18 car
parking spaces two of which will be for
the Sabre parking as part of the
proposal it is confirmed by the by the
school that the sixth form car parking
would be relocated to braze lane and the
proposed area car parking would be used
by the nursery only the proposed cow
bulk high and appearance are considered
it's acceptable especially against a
backdrop backdrop for the school
buildings given the single-story nature
of the proposed building and these
sufficient distances between the
proposed building and the surrounding
neighboring dwellings it is considered
that the proposed development would not
create situation of overlooking
overshadowing or over dominance the
hours of operation proposed are between
the hours hours or 7:30 a.m. and 6:30
p.m. Monday to Friday
vehicle movements would occur first
being the morning from 7:15 a.m. and
would be staggered for a day to
approximately 7:00 7:00 p.m. the open
air opposed and days of operation are
considered acceptable and would not have
a significant impact upon the
surrounding residents its proposed to
layer 18 car parking spaces adjacent to
nursery these spaces will be used by
nursery only the nursery is proposed to
employ 11 members of staff and therefore
the amount of car parking proposed would
be adequate and meet the council's
adopted parking standards
and an access road exits to the rear
existed really properties front in
Oxford Road and Spencer Gardens as part
of this proposal schools proposing to
use a vehicle access from Oxford Road to
gain access to the nursery and lead to
site by that provide access onto Spencer
Gardens currently the site is access and
exited from Oxford Road as part of this
access as part of this access is closed
off and has been for 20 years so it's
closed between East closed between the
entrance of the site and at Nina highway
of Spencer garden yeah can you point cuz
I didn't want to and yes so at the
moment that access is closed at Spencer
Gardens and it's also cleat closed near
the entrance of the site at the moment
and that has been closed for over 20
years and this is but this was resulted
as antisocial behavior problems were
occurring in this area and however
residents do also have access to these
garages and rear gardens by these gates
they will have a key to gain access to
this part of the access
so at Luxor is proposed to reopen access
to its full extent allowing vehicles to
access in Spencer garden from the
nursery
this means gates were currently situated
by the application site and near the
highway Spence garden would be removed
and seized a photograph so I'm going to
show you so so this is the gate at the
moment that's in place and this is
proposed to be removed as partner
development to allow vehicles to gain
access on Spencer garden this will
enable the school to create a safe
entrance into and and to exit from the
nursery in terms of highway safety
additionally as its County Council
highway authority was consulted and
raises no objections to the proposed
development and I would like to confirm
that this piece of land was transferred
to the school in 2011 by Essex County
Council when the school became an
academy if the school were to remove the
gates that are currently in institute
permission from the house would not need
to be sought by the school the app can
ask friends that site would be locked
when out of hours currently the site to
use by 6:00 for students for car parking
and used by members of the public during
the evenings and at weekends so looking
this site out of hours would prevent
this entrance being used late into the
evenings and at weekends and it is
considered that the proposed development
complies with policies of the
development plan and the MPP F and
therefore recommended for approval
subject to conditions Thank You mr.
Lewis this is going to speak on this one
up to five minutes let you know when
you've got a minute to go
good evening shout out as mentioned my
name is Simon Lewis I live at 104
Mayfield Avenue in Southend on C I'm
here in reference to the said
application for the day care nursery
ikemen school I'm speaking for and on
behalf the residents of - Spencer
gardens who are my parents and have
lived at the property for 43 years and
concerned residents of 25 27 and 29
Oxford Road all of which have formally
objected previously to the application
and have permitted me to speak on their
behalf we're objecting to the
application on the grounds of safety
congestion and impact to the
long-suffering neighbors of the school
specifically relating to the traffic
movements and opening of access refer to
any application as the Spencer gardens
and entrance photographic evidence has
been submitted previously to back up
this situation so first and foremost the
application includes the opening of a
narrow road the 3.6 meters wide leaving
on suspense Gardens which has not been
used for public or Vic Euler access for
in excess of 43 years if ever
so I let's Vic Euler access so it's also
been closed off for the last 25 years in
consultation with Essex police tutor
anti-social behavior
burglary and alleged drug dealing and
this was too full
if opened the resident residents would
be left vulnerable to such activities
once again and why we've seen in the
addendum that they're going to lock the
gates to the entrance this we feel does
not address vehicle moments around that
that access road from Eva entrance or
exit out of ours
so despite assurance that this exit
would be used for the nursery only there
is no details to suggest how this would
be managed or policed and currently
there is no such controls we therefore
believe that this will become an
extension to the current chaos with all
the users utilizing this route
including pupils trying to gain access
to the school and out of hours clubs
including Caravan rallies we have
documented in excess of a hundred parked
cars in the spices served body Oxford
Road exit access which is significantly
wider of five meters this was witnessed
on various days and times including
Saturdays and Sundays early into the
evening outside of this suggested out of
hours activity times in the application
or the original application Oceanside
notwithstanding this visibility at the
junction of Spencer Gardens is poor at
best with a two meter high solid fence
and garage obscuring views vehicles have
to obstruct the footpath prior to
ascertain if is safe to join at the
carry dry leaving pedestrians on the
primary school wrote at risk of injury
or worse both Spencer Gardens and Oxford
Road or chaotic gridlocked and unsafe
are busy times and this would only add
to the current problem as a highway
Junction this contravene the garden set
out in their six design guide we're sure
you will agree that opening this access
will have significant noise and
disruption impact on the residents
residents of Oxford Road will have
vehicles passing to the front and rear
of their properties we also feel this
would have a detrimental impact on the
value of their properties and the
residents privacy currently resonant
subjects into this application and
several several others have access
rights to Spencer Gardens entrance
routes of garages this would be
unreasonably restricted by the traffic
and would cause disruption and safety
risks to both parties the application
also states there will be no further
vehicle impact therefore we struggle to
see the justification for open this less
suitable Road one final point we're
aware that the Brys Lane car park is
often empty at weekends and was
originally permitted to ease the school
traffic impact if this was using it to
go
yeah I'm kind of problem if this was
used as intended and enforced it would
certainly ease the existing congestion
we urge you to carefully consider these
factors as part of determining the
application we feel you have the
opportunity to help the frustrated
residents and even improve congestion to
these minor roads we thank you for your
time thank you
cancer Stanley you've indicated Thank
You chairman concerns as what's been
indicated already is that the vehicles
going up and down that entrance that's
going to be opened it doesn't seem to be
for me why do you know for two vehicles
and I thought that emphasize it doesn't
seem to be yeah perhaps you could let me
know but the the amount of traffic how
much how many I can't remember how many
spaces you said that was there but
whatever the KC's coming off of Oxford
Road would would the occupants of the
nursery be the only ones to allocate the
nursery as well as the disabled parking
spaces and would Oxford Road be then
congested with parking throughout the
day to get to the nursery or is there a
way for the vehicles to go into the
nursery turn around and come out again
and it's wide enough for the two
vehicles depart each other it seems to
me that the garages at the back of those
properties in Oxford Road have that
right-of-way and would that be a
disturbance to those garages should
don't want to use that right-of-way
that's towards Oxford Road
I can't see I mean they've all from what
the pictures show there are quite a few
garages there and and if people was to
put their vehicles outside of the garage
they would be blocking the road bites at
these seams I've got you to clarify that
situation Thank You members just before
we get going I'm just going to ask for a
little bit of clarity because I feel
that the discussion might might get
diverted can I just clarify that we are
talking about a planning application in
the area marked within the redline and
from listening to the presentation that
the blue line represents the area that
is in the control of the applicant but
the actual routes to and from the
highway are not part of the application
they're part of the management plan yes
so the application site is that red but
on any application and applicant does
have to show extent within their control
to in the highway the adopted highway so
yeah the main nursery building is within
the red line but how they going to
access the site in this loop manner as
proposed location because any applicant
has to show how their development is
going to access the highway thank you
yes the Steptoe Thank You chairman come
to three points of clarification please
the officer said that the sixth form of
people parking and sixth formers would
be moved to parking tabrets Lane can you
clarify you mean to braceland carpark
not brace lane itself
place because that would be absolute
chaos yeah secondly with regards to the
entrance
yes I was concerned the chairman raised
a point as to whether we actually
looking at the planning there can you
tell me whether the accesses I have
already got established planning
permissions for use as accesses and
exits and secondly the large one that
comes off of Oxford Road will that be
one way or will that be to way I'm not
quite sure how that's going to work
because those people with the garages
there if that's one way they're going to
have to go around the loop but if it's
two-way people coming in kind of
conflicted people coming out of the
garages a little bit unclear as to how
that's going to work or take those
answers now because I think I may make
some of it thank you Karen I can confirm
that the six boom carpark will be
relocated to praise lane car park that's
part school ready historically these
accesses were used many years ago to
transport the children to school via bus
and this is where the buses used to park
before being relocated to brace link our
Park and this is what is historic useful
there was an application back in 2008
that reinforced had reinforced this
access by laying out reinforced hard
standing basically so it kind of could
have gone a date the buses and so
historically it's always been used as a
vehicle access to the school and that's
coming in from Oxford Road the access
out and Spencer Gardens I know that's
been closed for 20 odd years and I
believe the gentleman who spoke earlier
said that vehicles have an access to
site
I haven't the vehicles haven't used the
access on dispense garden for a number
of 40 odd years but I have no evidence
of that
back in confirmed that has been locked
up for over 20 years and on your third
point sorry you said about you have
concerns about cars going into the site
from what Oxford Road and crossing and
we've been the site if I show you
another plan and there is enough room in
sight to accommodate tea to accommodate
a turning circle if needed
that axis does measure six meters wide
so could potentially have two cars
crossing at the same time but again it
could restrict neighbors gain access to
the garages but then the situation at
the moment sixth form students are using
that access as it is at the moment and
whether they use it the two way I'm not
entirely too sure but I've got a number
of other people might get answered in
the other questions
so I go to counts the whole crane eggs
Thank You chairman you mentioned about
that the existing gates will be removed
but then there's going to be some new
security gates put in place so that out
of the time that the nursery is going to
be in use that these will be put in
place so that the actual site access
will be limited to certain times is that
correct if I clarify and the school are
proposing to remove those gates and as I
as I said in my presentation that access
count currently belongs to the school so
it doesn't require permission from the
council to remove those gates and the
gates in question that are going to be
locked are the gates allocated could you
point to the gate access so if these
gates here that they're referring to be
locked I mean at the moment I know that
that cars due access this site in
evening weekends so from those gates
being locked out of hours that will
prevent that situation in the in the
hope that because anybody using that
site hours will then go to Bray's Lane
and park yeah yeah thank you for that so
it would seem from what you're saying is
there's gonna be no restriction on the
access roads to the general public
they those roads will be open its the
gated area to the car park
yes that's correct yep that's it thanks
to chairman sorry having listened to the
members and talking to the officers and
also receiving some communication from
the officers with regards to the exit -
Spencer Gardens whether or not Spence
garden gate becomes operational again or
not is no major issue to the client or
the proposed developer or development
so we've already heard that the proposed
change to the carpark the transfer of
the Sixth Form parking etc be moved to
brazed
Lane car park and so conservative if we
only leave the way I'm so sorry why
sorry I would like to look at the
Spencer garden exit with regards to
putting a condition on the report of the
application where the the actual fences
or the the gates remain in place because
this reduces the traffic demand on the
site such that the Spencer garden exit
is not critical to the de ban or use as
stated by the school and your reason for
that the reason is from the the traffic
traffic demands if we remove it which
will be a noose nuisance and health and
safety issues towards the residence is
my first point the second point is exit
to Spencer Gardens and the restriction
of the width of the road going to
through to Spencer Gardens and also the
points which have already been raised by
the officer with regards to the
anti-social behavior and I appreciate
that if we do remove the barriers when I
can't predict whether that rule actually
returned or not but the antisocial
behavior which was recommended by the
police to actually enclose the the exit
- Spencer Gardens
all right okay well carry on with the
discussion and then see how things
evolve
that's the mrs. Horry
Thank You chairman first of all I want
to take you to 8.1 free number 10 where
it says the only now proposed nursery
always follows you 7:30 to 9:00 and then
and sund'ys and opening bank holidays
Mundy's but I don't see no condition to
say that it doesn't have to open or
Sunday or a bank holiday but then if you
go to item 11 it says the hour provides
between Monday to Friday reflects the
school opening hours but I mean I might
be wrong here but I thought the school
closed at 2 o'clock if I'm sorry on set
and yet you're these open hours stated
on improving the rapport is what the
applicant gave me as school opening
hours the addendum does clarify that the
nursery is proposed to be open between
7:30 a yes in 30 a.m. and close at 6:30
p.m. Monday to Friday
that doesn't include weekends it'll be
closed at weekends I just say that later
when the report that the site will be
closed during evenings any weekends and
the school open hours are to 9:30 that's
to accommodate for the evening clubs
that do take place there such as a
football and other activities thank you
I'm just little bit computer confused
about the parking you said there's gonna
be some new parking in brace lane for
the sixth formers I am I led to believe
I didn't say new I said they can be
relocated to the Braves line car park
they play on 8.13
number 7 it says a new car part will be
laid out to the side of the building and
it says these parking space that could
be shared between the proposed nursery
and sixth form students
no six bomb students have been relocated
to doesn't say that in the report well
so what paragraph 8 1 3 number 7
yes that that's clarified
within the addendum the second second
bullet point in the addendum it's
clarified that sixth formers won't be
using what was originally proposed
they'll be relocated to the existing car
park and bracelet okay thank him okay
counselor Gooding Thank You chairman
my concern was also the the car parking
area so the amount of car parking spaces
are 18 in total and if you've got
parents dropping the children off
there's going to be an awful loss space
is required and there's gonna be
pandemonium there as they usually is
with any parking spaces with schools
that's my concern
that's a Williams thank you chairman as
I understand it the pupils attending
cares will not be able to gain access to
the school from this development can you
confirm that place that's correct yes
chairman
how many yet do we know how many car
parking spaces are in use now by the
sixth form students and I do do
something sorry can I come back to you
on that point I do have there anything
she wanted to add yeah the reason I
asked is it's to do with the total
number of vehicle movements as the
number of movements that we've got as of
today with that being used as a car park
for the sixth form students as against
the potential number of movements with
the newest reference okay okay right
there only members wanting to speak you
haven't already spoken or assault the
second round councillor fatigue we're on
a1 number
23 says he only gives one spice to drop
off pickup surely that's not enough if
I'm reading that correctly first we're
talking off children okay right from
start second round then counselor step 2
Thank You chair um could we have the
drawing aware the entrances and exits
are back up on the screen please
yes I'm still I'm still somewhat a
little bit confused about this Spencer
Gardens access as to whether that has
got established planning permission for
users and access to the site secondly
with the number of properties in Oxford
Road that back on to that exit or any of
those buildings carriages that are in
current use because if that is the case
then it's obviously been used since
since then so I've still got a bit of
concern as to whether there is an
established juice there yeah I think
they've said their permission is in
place to use the exits onto entrance or
exit from Spencer Gardens however for a
considerable amount of time minimum 20
years it has not been used
yes yes and as Anna T and it's been
isolated by by fencing during that time
counts the hawk way Thank You German
just like to get a clarification is it
intended that the nursery building and
the car parking area which is adjacent
to it which is meant for that that
facility is that gonna be completely
separated from the rest of the school
with some kind of security fencing they
have our fences there at the moment and
there is a gate Palestine fencing in
place at the moment the safeguarding of
the young children that will be locked
at all times to prevent the school the
nursery and the school mix in basically
okay so that's already existing
yeah that's already existing thank you
right come back to counselor
y'all knew that place Thank You me Thank
You chairman with regards to the
condition I placed earlier I would also
like to add to the condition that a
turning circle is in place
in the car park to alleviate a two-way
stream of traffic down to down Oxford
Road
I think the way I'm obviously sensing
the the way the discussions going we're
we're not interested not not interested
the the principle of the permission for
a nursery in that location the design of
the nursery that's not in question this
is about the management of the egress
and access throught froth from from the
nursery so I think members need a deal
of clarity about whether we're talking
about actual planning issues whether
we're talking about traffic management
plans how it all how it all forms
because the the it seems to me that the
core of the planning application is is
not in question here did you have a
whilst they accept this question was
gone that this was it's currently a
two-way access route from Oxford Road my
understanding or said it would become a
one-way loop is that not the case that
that's the principle of the application
yes okay thank you so so the
clarification on the access so at
present the only access point for
vehicles to this area is via Oxford Road
because there is a gate here that's been
there for a long time there are I think
twelve sixth-form parking spaces that
are used in this location so we're
talking about a slight increase in the
number of vehicle movements but perhaps
not you know its significantly or
excessively so in relation to the
nursery at the moment the sixth form
parking would be accessed so via Oxford
Road so it would be two-way traffic down
here what they're proposing in this
application is that parents drop up you
know enter by Oxford Road to drop off
their children and then exit via Spencer
Gardens
I think the school have indicated that
they don't have to have that arrangement
so essentially they could adopt the same
arrangement that they exists for the
sixth form students there is space
within the layout within the red line
for parents to drop off and then turn so
there's a turning circle in the layout
to enable them to go back down Oxford
Road I think the difficulty officers
have is potentially with a condition
saying that this gated access must
remain there needs to be a justifiable
planning reason for that
so highway safety issues around access
points are you know reasons why you
might object to an access point we don't
have Essex County Council highways
objecting to the arrangement by which
this is proposed okay so for clarity at
present the entrance to Oxford Road is
two-way let's propose one way yeah yet
the access dispenser Gardens has been
closed it's been proposed has been
opened going one way council you all
knew you you mentioned a an additional
condition one relating to highways
unfortunately highways would not support
us in an appeal situation and at this
moment in time no one's offered to
second you on on on that one
so I was hoping we've got through is it
a fresh point
where I'm wary of suggestions in the we
we have to judge the application that's
presented for us it's not for us to
modify it on their behalf rather than
necessarily supporting cancer early in
the our news a suggestion of making a
condition is it more appropriate by only
mine what's been put before us that we
put an informative down with our point
of view in relation to the access on to
Spencer Gardens so that we give an
opinion and then it's for the school to
determine how it once wants to take take
that forward is that is that appropriate
it would be appropriate and I would
anticipate regardless of what we do that
the trustees of the the King Edmund
Academy would be exceptionally concerned
about their relationships with their
neighbors and would be on the front foot
when discussing how their application
would influence their lives might be
somewhat disappointed if they weren't
giving that active consideration yes I
do take your point I think that's fair
enough
yes kennel chair another clarification
point and we are talking about the the
red box and the concern is around access
to the red box and because the
application is about the metaphorical
red box and they could change their
arrangements on access is my
understanding or they could decide to go
in a different direction
and making some of this moot is that
correct
so we'll we're just at one final comment
before we we try and tie this up and
please there is a red line but any
application must demonstrate appropriate
access to the highway and so we can
consider does this nursery site have
appropriate access to a highway
this is edged blue but it's in the
ownership so it's in the control of the
applicant so we can be satisfied that
although it's not edged red it is still
full consideration the access to this
use and it can be achieved because it's
edged blue it's in their control but it
is in the schools gift to determine if
you like because two-way traffic down
here because there's turning within the
site is an option so it's in the option
it's kind of within the school's gift
because essentially either option for
planning purposes officer say is
acceptable I agree with counsel the hawk
way with the point is race because and
also yourself chairman based off
communications through the officer from
from the school the school have not got
in they're not concerned about utilizing
the Spencer cut the sensor garden exit
because it's not critical to their
demand so I still think that we should
put in an option rather than condition
to say informative yet informative to to
that point thank you members we have a
motion I'll move the motion for approval
printed on 8.1 16 but to go with that
and informative that does highlight to
the the school the concern of the
council with regards to its traffic
management that it hopes that the
trustees of the school won't be very
attentive to their resident neighbors
and actively look to monitor manage and
adapt to the situation should it be
required okay thank you those members in
favor of the approval please indicate
those against that item is approved
thank you our next item item 824 CID our
Road Raley removal of condition 3 on
planning application which was a change
of use from workshop to Jim Thank You
chairman this proposed is to vary your
planning condition imposed on an earlier
planning permission relating to 24 CID I
rode in railing apologies but if you can
follow the line the application site is
this sort of triangular plot here the
application site is on the Brook Road
Industrial Estate adjoining part of the
estate's northern boundary the site is
accessed via by car via Brook Road to
the south which links to the high road
and rail II where the site is within
close proximity of residential
properties on woodlands Avenue to the
north a single industrial type building
occupies the site shown on the plan in
that in the sorry in that dark outline
planning permission was granted to
change the use of this building to a gym
in 2017 the planning consent was granted
subject to a number of conditions one of
which limited the use to one to one
fitness training and group training for
up to ten people at a time with sessions
pre-booked
it is this condition that the applicant
now seeks to remove the applicant
contends it is hard to allow the
business to grow with this restricted
condition in place and that the
condition results in the building being
underutilized the applicant would like
to branch out and work with overweight
children however with parents attending
classes to the restriction of ten
persons at a time would not allow for
this the key issue in the determination
of this application relates to the
adequacy of the proposed parking
arrangements at the site although the
condition was imposed for reasons
relating also to intensification of use
and impact on residential amenity
conditions limited limiting noise
transfer from the
would remain in place the applicant has
also submitted some photographs there
are a lot I'll just quickly take you
through them so this is the rear of the
building and there's this area here and
as you'll see when we get onto the
photos from the front elevation it's
sorry the applicant isn't able to use
all this for parking as well as the
front because you sort of block this
access to the rear with the parking that
you have at the front of the building if
you can quickly sorry I couldn't manage
to get the photos broken up so they're
all together so we'll just quickly go
through some of them which show the
interior of the building which has been
kitted out as a gym if you can keep
going through those then this is the
front of the sites and you can see that
there's parking to the frontage of some
of the other units on the industrial
estate there's some parking restrictions
and then there's some on street parking
availability further down again sorry
this is just the interior yeah so this
is the part of the frontage so it's a
bit of an awkward shaped plot we've got
the building and then you've got this
parking available to the side so what
have you got you've got five cars
they're a couple of vans motorbike to
the front and then the next one should
show the frontage so again the pub that
the applicant has surfaced the front and
can park a number of vehicles at the
front but obviously then accessing that
rear area although the some additional
space can't all be utilized for parking
the applicant has submitted these photos
to demonstrate that there is 15 car
parking spaces within the site in the
earlier 2016 change views application
five parking spaces were shown to be
provided on a site layout plan the
photos clearly show the ability to of
the site to part more than five cars
although it does mean tandem
arrangements with some cars blocking
others in
the adopted parking standard works on
maximum parking numbers for uses such as
gyms subject to the need to ensure
adequate provision for the size of
building the maximum parking requirement
will be calculated to be 30 spaces given
that the greater on-site parking
provision can be achieved them as
originally considered it is considered
appropriate to allow for a greater
number of people to use the gym at any
one time
officers recommend that the condition be
very to limit the number of users of the
building to a maximum of 30 if you go
back to the site plan so I think the
concern of the concern of some residents
on round Wooden's
Avenue in relation to the parking issue
is that this footpath link access up
here so potentially overflow car parking
does happen or could happen in woodlands
Avenue with people then walking to
access the gym here equally people can
access from the south and park in other
areas of the Industrial Estate members
should also be aware of 32 letters of
support the application has been
received these letters refer to the gym
helping the local community with health
and fitness and the site having ample
parking the letters were received from
residents of the Rochford district but
also as well in adjoining districts
generally from users of the gym one
respondent first using the gym and
parking within the site or if not at
other times within the Industrial Estate
when you know when other units are
closed and there has been consent
allowed for that parking one refers to
the parking at site being managed well
to ensure that space for people
attending classes that they're all
pre-booked onto subject to the proposed
conditions including the variation of
condition 3 to allow for up to 30 people
at one time to use the building officers
recommend approval of the application
just a reminder members has one tiny
little bit of extra information on the
addendum now we have a speaker on this
one mr. Daniels
after five minutes I'll let you know
when you got a minute to go
Oh Thank You chairman committee my night
smart Daniels someone I'm Lisa Minot I'm
here on behalf of the applicant Robert
barber four months ago I found out I was
here white liver disease and I was told
by my consult and now I must get fit and
I must go and sink I Jim and I heard
about this Jim that mr. Bob aids as
you've seen locating Brook for growing
industrial state and I went along and
after so I was very impressed from what
he achieved with me and what he was
achieving with others and I think it's
that achievement they he's done with
myself and with others that um I said I
would come and speak on this application
because he would miss father is in the
business of helping people people I
myself who became ill and as new
officers mentioned he also wants to help
children we all know everyone sitting in
here that we have begun into a time of
increasing child obesity and having the
cap on how many people can visit the gym
obviously whatever the fetch they won't
be able to get so many children in with
their parents turning up and supporting
their children so I think it's very
important that you know that that cap
could be lifted or may be shifted in
some way we also agree to provide an
increase for those who participate could
open a possibility of employing
part-time coaches to teach these
children particularly maybe like single
parents returning to work it's a great
you know it's a great business again so
if between those hours that you you can
work or might be school school hours
also another mr. barber is also
interested in might be teaching someone
who is a school leaver
to be a coach within that Jim so but
obviously with that cap you can't have
these people in there because there's
only ten people can be allowed at one
time no no there's been some negative
comments but as you investigating shows
within your documentation or there is
ample parking and they could be parking
put roundabouts
as well Oh sides that many people lock
myself I share a car with my wife when
we go people ride their bikes there and
is that and there's an actual bike rack
for people to store their their bikes
and also some work from the local
community food early they say there are
people within Riley that are using the
gym so they can walk there and as you
send pictures all the cars because they
are because in the in the in a planning
permission they're really grantees they
are set times so the cars will come and
they will go there's not any for a
backlog because they are set classes
it's not a like a normal open gym where
people just turn up now and again and as
for the noise has been proven by can
your investigation there and there is no
significant noise to the residents
probably not as much noise as the
industrial strike causes now to be
honest with their lorries and the coming
to go in say along that road and as a
canceled I know that you suppose from
small businesses and entrepreneurs and
people who work hard to inject money
into the local economy members of the
gym regularly walk into Riley and my
particular in summer and as it's quite
close and spend their money in a coffee
a sees another businesses nearby like
base Chambliss just down the road on
either quite a few team members take
their kids down there when you know they
leave the gym so all of these things we
injected money we've been into the local
community and I think it's a great thing
I know right he canceled have sent their
objection Bob release is short-sighted
and sends out the wrong message to those
throughout the health of the local
community mind my hope this cancer and
it's committee will see the benefits and
even if you can't agree on a cap of 30
my hope a cap more than 10 will be
granted so mr. barber can get his
business up and running because I think
it's a very good local business and it's
done very well and that's why I sit in
front of you today so thank you very
much great thank you thank you thank you
council award
Thank You chairman again you know I do
appreciate what the gentleman has said
with regard to businesses I think we we
always would want to be there supporting
local businesses to improve and expand I
think when this originally came to
council I think the shame of it was that
it's just in the wrong place and it's
always been in the wrong place because
it's right on woodlands avenue and it's
very near and of course with everything
that's going on we know that people may
say well you bought a house that's on an
industrial site and near to an
industrial site but of course the hours
worked on an industrial site are a lot
less than these hours it would be an
exception of maybe from 8 o'clock in the
morning until maybe six o'clock at night
and no work at weekends so it's the type
of thing that would have been acceptable
but as it stands at the moment I would
like members to be drawn to why
condition three was recommended in the
first place and how important both
conditions five and six are which I know
are looking to be retained anyway I
think where the parking issue came into
it and I'd like to deal with that
parking issue because it does affect the
members that the residents who live in
woodlands Avenue but to be honest I
think this is an issue that needs to be
dealt with by set because I believe that
is something the residents will need to
decide with regard to the parking
restrictions if it does increase so
that's something I would recommend that
we need to look at so I would like to
take the main reason I would say that I
asked for this to be brought through
before this committee I noticed that
this site had previously been
investigated on three separate occasions
in connection with alleged breaches of
conditions five and six under the
application an original application
these cases were subsequently resolved
and the respective cases closed but my
first question would be as to as
Tyrannis a rhetorical question actually
is why were they investigated on three
separate occasions in the first place
and my answer would be because those
conditions were breached I'm concerned
on one particular breach occasion when
an excessive noise complaint was being
investigated microphones were placed in
one of the houses as part of the
investigation which was a but in the gym
and is a five day investigation and as
part of that five day investigation the
investigation team felt it reasonable to
inform the gym that they were being
monitored for noise nuisance now so it's
no surprise that neighbors over that
five day period noticed how quiet the
gym was with one neighbor wondering if
they'd gone out of business so I feel
that on this occasion I believe that
decision that the case be closed as
there was no case to answer was
seriously flawed which again brings some
doubt to my mind
and something which I hope you will all
consider on how the previous
investigations were conducted and
whether I also flawed in some way I
believe what this committee are being
asked to improve is through a three-fold
increase in what is often intolerable
noise from the gym plus the nuisance of
increased parking in woodlands which
I've already addressed with regard to
SEP so I think we shouldn't really look
at that in conversations I've had with
the residents about this application
I've been told that both conditions five
and six are being continually ignored
and broken surely as it stands this is
in content of what this committee had
originally recommended to ameliorate the
issues that were previously highlight as
essential on the original application
so I would like to suggest that if this
committee is minded to approve the
removal of condition three which the
owner argues is detrimental to the
ongoing success of his business which I
do understand
I believe additional conditions on
soundproofing and air conditioning which
were previously not included because it
was considered by this committee could
jeopardize the viability of the business
at the time should now be reconsidered
view of this proposed change and I would
also ask this committee to seriously
consider revisiting conditions five and
six with a recommendation that periodic
monitoring should take place without
notice so as to enable correct and
accurate measurements being taken to
assess any breaches finally I would ask
you to put yourselves in the residence
situation which raises concerns for the
long-term mental effects that noise
nuisance can cause thank you very much
Jim cancer Stanley Thank You chair but
what can you say today it's not
compulsory no it's not and I was just
know very true all I would say was is
that I think we have an entrepreneur
that wants to make people fitter wants
to improve his business and in fact the
residence adjacent to him can always go
in there and use the facilities as well
as for parking well the highway is the
highway and unfortunately he doesn't
control the highway and neither do we
so that is something for the highways to
to determine as to how they want to
control traffic the the the purpose of
this
increase in membership I would imagine
that he would have more if you like you
examine not examiner's but trainers to
come to this site will use the site to
train their people in groups so to train
those people and obviously we do have
with a problem with obesity in children
and and this is probably a very very
good idea too to try and get them fit
for purpose I don't see I mean that the
parking area is if you was to have the
same people that are in row if
Industrial Estate where you've got
scaffolding going on would that rather
be a scaffold distribution place or
would we have it as that because the
residents at the back on the EON saw it
do have that sort of thing and they
start at hop our 6:00 in the morning and
don't finish till 9:00 o'clock at night
when they're unloading so I think on the
basis that these people are starting at
a reasonable hour and finishing at a
reasonable where I don't think that's a
detriment to that so anybody okay that's
the mountain
thank you Joe and just I'd like to get
the committee back in in mind of what
councillor Ward was was saying I think
the points that were raised in relation
to noise pollution and possibly
soundproofing and periodic monitoring
was very relevant and I don't know if
they can be added as conditions thank
you
okay right we'll move on to members then
can't slam me on as a ward councillor
just to read revisit well he waters
saying councillor me award as a lodge
counselor I've been down woodlands Anton
you a number of times and these are very
valid complaints and yeah and the other
thing is that I would go further than
just soundproofing I'd have insist that
you have equipment that actually
switches the power off to the amplifiers
if they go above a certain level this
equipment is Craig you'll early fitted
in the church halls and all sorts of
other areas and it actually physically
prevents the racket because I believe
the residents and unfortunately I also
believe this business of monitoring and
and informing will result in the volume
being turned now the other problem is
and Rian's right about SEP is that the
parking down there is already diabolical
and there's issues with the county
council not replacing white lines which
might come in our area but people are
actually being trapped in their own
driveway already so their concerns are
that it will just get worse and they are
really right on top of the places an
alley at the side so I would suggests
that equipment there actually monitors
and shuts down those amplifiers has
insisted as a condition that's the hot
way thank you Kevin what clarify matter
with emphasis on the provided it would
seem the there's an access road that
runs around the hole of the building is
that correct yeah so he's possible that
in the first photograph that we were
shown with the piece of hard standing
that was had the overgrowth of greenery
on it just not used currently for
parking that there is access directly
onto that that's that piece of hard
stone well well there is an act sorry
there is an access track shown there but
there isn't actual
access so and I don't know that
so the Oni on this application the only
bit that we consider is the red line and
the ownership the rights of access over
any of the other parts it is not known
at this point in time so all we know is
that the site has access to CID our Road
to the front and so they can access to
the front to this part here and they can
access to the back but because of the
awkward shape it means that you know
putting cars at the back would
essentially mean that you know you're
losing some space and it might well be
an option but the applicant hasn't put
that option forward to us and that track
is unmade as well thank you chafing able
to come back mmm unfortunately because
of the drawing we have in front of us it
doesn't have the red line outline so
it's a bit difficult for us to ascertain
exactly where it is but what you're
saying is although the although it shows
that there is some form of access there
it's in reality it doesn't really exist
as an access point okay thank you it's
the Wilson so my point relates to
counsel hook ways as well so when I
remember the original application all of
the parking was at the front so where
it's shown on the photograph now but was
shown that the photograph at the back
we're saying that that cut that cannot
be used or it can be found
sorry yeah yes it's all gated off at the
moment so whilst there is a truck on the
northern side of that there's no means
of the sites you know accessing through
here it's not clear from the application
that there they have the right to use
this it could be under different
ownership so whilst this area is within
the site boundary and ideally you'd
utilize every spare inch for parking on
the site the the difficulty is the
awkward shape and that you know you have
to access down here at the moment unless
the applicant tells suppose otherwise
that they could potentially provide an
access point through here so I wasn't
thinking - the one on the right I was
actually thinking we can see the car
there so we're saying that that's not
useable then you can use here yeah
that's within the application site so
the applicant could provide this areas
additional parking the difficulty is is
actually how many spaces can you achieve
in this area versus how many can you
achieve at the front unless you're going
to have the same arrangement and just
sort of have everybody coming in and
blocking everybody in there's no reason
why you know we couldn't sort of you
know suggest the well it's clear they
can use that area for parking if they
can see a way to make it work with
everybody just going in everybody
leaving at the same time so there's no
difficulty with people being blocked in
could you just give members a little bit
of clarity on whether they can or the
relevance of the conditions that have
been suggested with regard to monitoring
air-conditioning sound
sound equipment and so on so this is an
application to very conditioned three
well actually the applicant wants to
remove condition three in our offices
have suggested that we very condition
three and allow thirty people to use the
gym any one time and in doing so there
is an intensification of the use and
that is part and parcel of what
condition three was referring to at the
outset so potentially there is potential
for the imposition of additional
conditions as long as there is a valid
reason for imposing additional
conditions that weren't originally
proposed on the original application so
it's within members gift to propose new
conditions we just need to be sure that
firstly they weren't already dealt with
by the conditions that are going to be
reimpose which will be carried forward
and that they need to be a real planning
reason for imposing new conditions all
right members we've got an application
this I'm sensing that there is a a will
to support business to to allow this to
develop but it is the concern over the
impact but I am in your hands as to
whether you have any planning reasons
which would substantiate additional
conditions being added to help support
this this application so I'll come to
Council step toe check can I suggest
that we add the extra condition if we
increase the number to thirty then the
appropriate monetary equipment is
provided by the applicants for our use
adjacent to the site to make sure that
it
doesn't increase the noise levels etc
and if it does appropriate action there
needs to be taken to bring it back to
the correct level so I'm not conditioned
additional conditions can be imposed the
difficulty with additional conditions is
that they need to be very precise so we
need to ensure that the condition meets
five tests just one of those is that
it's precise another that it's
enforceable so what we need to be
careful is that we're very clear about
exactly what we're asking the applicant
to do is it ongoing you know it needs to
be time limited to ensure that if it is
any breach going forward residents you
know have comfort that we could actually
enforce it reasonably said I think the
the basis is that it makes sure that it
does not increase any neighbor
disturbance by increasing the numbers I
think members but been to a variety of
venues will have seen noise limiting
equipment that will automatically cut
power to amplified music should it go
beyond a particular point
are you well I'm yeah I think certainly
would have to set a decibel level yes
because the condition needs to be
precise and the issue is are we looking
at it was something just with because
that's the last suggestion was setting
something that would cut music within
the building if it reached a certain
level I had sort of understood the other
suggestion to be something on a boundary
I understand the reason for the
condition and I think that's acceptable
in that we're increasing the intensity
of the use and the number of users
potentially and we're seeking to ensure
that there is still a good relationship
with the neighboring residential
properties to the north I think the
issue of these wording of these
conditions is crucial and it I don't
know if it's well I think members we
will struggle to some extent tonight to
prop precision on levels of volume and
so on it is something that I believe we
would take professional officer advice
on environmental health god one more go
I was going to suggest the baseline
where we had caused to said plan
enforcement along to have a look at the
existing that the baseline was set at
that part because that wasn't a problem
very challenging with that one on the
basis that we are seeking further
technical and detailed information I'm
going to propose that this mess be
deferred until such time as we were see
before before we go go to that can I
have clarity from members because when
once we come back with this if we agree
to defer it was simply to be for the
agreement or not of the the new proposal
so we are number one
looking at monitoring equipment
to cut off the noise right there was a
second one the possibility of the
installation of soundproofing material
on the basis of the increased in usage
would mean potentially increasing noise
I think you start to cut across the
first one there because if you're not
creating noise louder than a certain
point whether you have the soundproofing
level or not we'll look at the acoustic
properties cancer FD decibel level needs
to be agreed at the boundary used used
at the boundary of the land occupied
aloneness by the gym challenging there I
believe the second point was around air
conditioning and I believe this is
because they're opening windows when
people get warm working out etc if more
people are working out more heaps I
suppose would be generated therefore the
one to open the windows with increase I
believe councillor Ward addict and I
point on introducing air conditioning to
resolve that and I wonder if that's
something where it's housed in a
condition I agree it's worth
investigation but where area of air
conditioning plan making its own noise
low level distraction I don't want it
just to come up with it a rat a random
shopping list do you want to just
comment on the viability of that's been
said I think in the round looking at
them sort of taken together so so we
could perhaps take some advice from our
colleagues environmental health and then
discuss with the applicant what they
might be willing to propose or look at
in a revised proposal to you and then
bring it back and we can see if whether
we can get some precise conditions that
might deal with these issues as we can
I'm not free determining in any way
the decision that the committee will
make but prior to is going to determine
the the sense that are receiving is that
providing sufficient safeguards can be
put in place on the areas mentioned the
committee is what the safeguards are
outlining the committee's concerns on
this item counts a snap town thank Jeff
I'm not really happy about deferment
because I don't think we should be
stringing this out any longer going to
tears but once the environmental health
are reported back to officers surely
that can be done within greement with it
with the war counselors the war
counselors are here this evening and
we're very aware of our concerns and can
work within that that parameters
counselor hook why did move for
deferment and he was seconded at there
at this point so I'm bound to go to that
point but you you made your points I
would hope that we could have a quick
turnaround to avoid unnecessary delay
and perhaps by the the form January
meeting we will be able to bring this
one back so on the motion to defer this
item based on the discussion that we've
had this evening those members in flavor
of the deferment please indicate
those against the deferment that item is
deferred right I again sorry for the
delay at the starts thank you for
attending and happy Christmas
[Music]